first thing I gasps Gary are you okay
man like you were pretty angry I think
Saturday night right with social media
no because I was I was defending a sport
that I dearly love and that boxing I
mean that this fight Saturday night with
Mayweather McGregor like I said before
it was a scam and it was a fraud I mean
that's exactly what I mean what did you
expect
you know Mayweather for the first four
rounds
didn't do anything I mean when has
Mayweather not done anything for the
first four round and ironically the
fight gets soft in the 10th round
and-and-and-and reports are that
Mayweather ban on himself in the 10th
round I mean this is what people you
know they were they were suckered in and
and and and what I want to what I want
to tell everyone is that look I mean
this is exactly what Mayweather is and
my argument against that Oscar is just
that you publicly said you wanted to
make mcgregor vs Canelo
why is McGregor Canelo less of a farce
than McGregor Mayweather there wouldn't
have been any no scam whatsoever in that
fight you don't think Mayweather stood
toe-to-toe well he did what he had to do
he did what he was capable of doing I
mean look just because just because you
have a cobra in there and and and it's
like the Cobra and the fairest who's
gonna win but ferret right but everybody
thought and everybody thinks that
McGregor is this big giant inside the
boxing ring it's no he's he's a giant in
the Octagon and it's two different
sports it's you know this Chris I mean
boxing is it's pure boxing is you know
the way you hit the speed bag the way
you jump the rope the way you move on
your feet the way you throw punches it's
a whole different sports in the MMA
McGregor is the best at what he does in
the UFC boxing is totally different I
agree with you and I I didn't go to the
fight I took that much issue with it but
I was more indifferent to an Oscar I
thought it was a one-off Mayweather came
out of retirement he was gonna do this
fight I didn't
it would have any impact on boxing
long-term do you think it will look a
lot of no I don't think it will because
that we have we have a great great fight
coming up with with Canelo and triple G
but I just feel bad for the fans who
paid their hard-earned money for it
that's all and I mean a lot of people
were telling me at the at the suburb
center when I was promoting Cotto which
by the way with a sellout crowd was
telling me look I mean it's it's we're
we're very disappointed but we're
looking forward to Canelo and triple G
which is a real tight if McGriff Canelo
beats golovkin and McGregor wants to
fight Canelo would you make that fight
no I won't because it will not it will
not be a competition it will not be a
fight I mean it's like I said look I
respect the UFC the UFC fans I respect
them for loving McGregor for loving
their athletes I respect I really do but
it's just two totally different sports
don't you think that Canelo though if he
made Canelo McGregor before this fight
that he would have just starched
McGregor within three rounds that's what
Canelo does that's what Canelo he always
delivers you a great a great show and
and look I mean I'm just looking forward
to Canelo triple G it's going to be an
amazing fight September 16th but but I
just want to say to all those fans who
who bought into the into the fight look
I'm sorry for what happened but look uh
at least we have something good to look
forward to on September 16 I think your
guys in trouble in the 16th Oscar I
really do it's a fight it's a tough
fight and look but this is this is
exactly what why we're in the sport is
it to take risks and this is a real
fight and may the best man win but uh
I'm telling you one thing for sure
September 16th it's gonna be bombed away
here's my question about Canelo Oscar
and this fights been I don't want to use
the word marinating because that's well
known in boxing circles as a negative
but you waited to pad this fight in in
2017 since that time since you first
kind of start to put this off a little
bit
Canelo fought Amir Khan he fought Liam
Smith and he
fought Julio Cesar Chavez Jr three
fights that I just don't know if they've
prepared him for what he's going to face
against Chavez Jr do you think the
Canelo is more prepared now than he was
two years ago to face golovkin well the
only thing I know is that he is a
middleweight now he did fill him he's
he's if you take a look at him right now
he looks like a tank and that's exactly
what we were waiting for I mean this guy
he was fighting at 154 pounds he was a
54 pounder
yes he fought a couple of times at 55
but he's a he's a fifty four pounder he
made he made 154 against Liam Smith at
the Cowboys Stadium last year alone I
mean so but right now look I hope he's
ready because the lobsters gonna come
with everything do you think that
golovkin has lost a step in his last
couple of fights no no no golovkin lost
unless he faced he faced a Daniel Jacobs
who is a amazing amazing box I mean I I
promoted take herbs all his career and
he's an amazing boxer he's uh he's the
miracle child he's uh he's the one who
you know he keeps getting better he's
fast he's uh he's got great movement you
know he gave the last in trouble I mean
golovkin human and and then he showed it
on that night when he fought Donnell
Jacob so I just think that look Canelo
with triple G it's gonna be one of those
style matches where we're gonna get an
exciting fight if Canelo wins will you
call out Mayweather for a rematch my guy
might get knocked out all Canelo my low
Triple D out of the water it might be a
great guy I mean who knows I have to
wait and see I mean that we Canelo wants
to go after the very best at 160 pounds
and that's the bottom line as someone
that fought Mayweather who promoted
Mayweather
now that Mayweather's officially done or
least he says he is what do you think
his legacy is respecting that day as a
boxer who is one of them best defensive
boxers of our generation I mean is
hands-down I mean there's no
there's no disrespecting his skills I
just was very disappointed and in but
you're as good as your last fight and a
lot of people sauce and who came up to
me yeah we're just very disappointed at
what took place on Saturday night how
many times have you watched your oh
seven fight with Mayweather I probably
watched it twice
just twice yeah good point
what'd you think when you watched it do
you have any regrets what how many years
before would you have needed to have
beaten Mayweather probably just one you
know I mean one one year of the
lifestyle that I was living is like is
like 10 years you know of deterioration
I mean I obviously when I was uh when I
was at the end of my career I challenged
Mayweather and and it was a very very
close fight where obviously a lot of
people thought that I pulled it off but
uh if there was a year before I mean
obviously we all know what would have
happened when was the last time you put
on a pair of gloves a pair of gloves
probably about since I retired really
I'm here to put on a pair of gloves
because I think I might get the it's to
come back and fight one more time you
think if you put on gloves you might
feel like you want to come back oh yeah
I mean it I love boxing
quit I love boxing and that's the reason
why I became a promoter it's to is to
defend my sport the integrity of the
sports and that's the reason why I was
so vocal look and and I knew the outcome
I knew what was going to take place and
so uh now now it's my job as a promoter
to bring you guys the best fight
possible and that's what I'm gonna do
September 16 if you could come back for
one fight who would it be against I will
probably challenge Sugar Ray Leonard
how old is Sugar Ray in the [ __ ] Matt
well Oscar you write about the 16th the
biggest fight the most significant fight
think in boxing Canelo Alvarez Gennady
golovkin t-mobile Arena September 16
catch that on HBO pay-per-view looking
forward to seeing you out in Vegas Oscar
and thanks for taking some time to join
me here on the show
you got about menu beggin that's Oscar
De La Hoya the promoter Golden Boy
Promotions former opponent of Floyd
Mayweather the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience